ah ça c'est relance à j'ai reconnu avec
le disait peut-être comme moi
particulièrement sensible aux odeurs
c'est mon côté animal et même si vous
n'êtes pas particulièrement sensibles
vous l'avez forcément remarqué à moins
d'être privé de doha on a tous des
odeurs corporelles toulouse ou moins
marqué on pourrait même dire qu'on a
tous une odeur corporelle composée de
toutes nos odeurs corporelles
la première la plus évidente c'est celle
de notre transpiration ou plutôt celle
de nos transpiration parce qu'on a deux
types de glandes sudoripares c'est à
dire les glandes qui produisent notre
sueur les glandes et crimes qu'on a un
petit peu partout sur le corps et qui
produisent une sueur qui contient pas
grand chose à part de l'eau et du sel et
qui s'évapore très vite et les glandes
apocrines qui l envoie une sueur
beaucoup plus riches en éléments assez
divers mais le genre que les bactéries
aime bien avec tout ce que ça implique
comme conséquence olfactives et celle là
et sont situés je vous laisse deviner au
niveau des aisselles de l'anus des
organes génitaux et des tétons oui on en
a déjà parlé un loader c'est les
bactéries qui mangent la sueur et qui
crottes et plus elle mange riche qu elle
crottes donc notre odeur corporelle elle
est déjà déterminé par les bactéries
qu'on héberge parce qu'on n'a pas tous
exactement les mêmes ou en tout cas pas
dans les mêmes quantités
par exemple si nos pieds sans que le
fromage c'est parce que parmi les
bactéries qui sont dans cette zone il ya
des brésil bactéries homme qui sont les
mêmes que celles qu'on utilise pour la
fabrication du maroilles par exemple et
qui produisent en acide qui s'appelle
l'acide is ova les rich et qui est à
l'origine de l'odeur caractéristique
mais ça aussi on en avait déjà parlé
donc ça c'est la base mais notre état
psychologique il joue aussi parce que le
stress ou l'anxiété par exemple ça
stimule davantage nos glandes apocrines
savez celle qui fabrique la sueur bien
riche là qui nourrit bien les bactéries
donc quand on dit tu pues le stress m'a
parfois c'est au sens propre premier
degré ensuite évidemment il ya tout ce
qui est lié à notre environnement et nos
habitudes de vie les substances avec
lesquels on est en contact en fonction
de là où on vit là où on travaille le
parfum et le déaut con mais et c est
aussi se consume ce qu'on mange ce qu'on
voit les médicaments qu'on prend et
c'est parce que tout ça ça influence
notre honneur notre allen et nos pères
déjà bien sûr qu'ils participent
forcément un petit peu au truc mais pas
seulement il ya aussi un grand nombre de
ces substances qui passent dans la
transpiration
d'ailleurs notre odeur en fait elle peut
donner plein de renseignements sur nous
elle peut traduire des troubles
métaboliques pour le diabète par exemple
dans le cas d'hyperglycémie c'est-à-dire
de taux trop élevé de sucre dans le sang
ça donne à la laine mais aussi à la
transpiration une odeur d'acétone on dit
que ça sent la pomme de reinette sais
pas si ça me parle plus que l'acétone
cessation et puis il ya aussi la trim et
si l'habit mûri vous connaissez alors
comment expliquer on appelle ça aussi le
syndrome de l'odeur du poisson pourri ça
vous parle plus
ouais la voûte et imagé
bon je vous la fait courte mais en gros
c'est causé par le manque d'une enzyme
bien particulière qui est indispensable
à l'organisme pour métaboliser latry
métier la mine la tri mais si la mine
c'est une substance qu'on trouve dans
l'alimentation par exemple et qui a la
particularité de sentir le poisson le
poisson pourri quand elle est dégradée
normalement par l'organisme pas de
problème mais chez les gens qui ont un
déficit dans la fameuse enzymes et
s'accumule dans l'organisme et elle est
évacuée par la respiration l'uriné et la
transpiration
autant vous dire que c'est handicapant
alors tout ça c'est pour les odeurs
qu'on perçoit facilement voire trop
facilement mais il ya aussi des odeurs
qui donne des indications sur notre état
de santé et qu'on perçoit pas en tout
cas pas forcément pas si on est un être
humain
deux exemples d'abord il ya des chiens
qui flaire les cancers on a découvert
que des chiens pouvait sentir certaines
cellules cancéreuses à travers la peau
avec un taux de réussite de quasi 100%
une équipe de l'institut curie de paris
est en ce moment en train de mener un
projet qui vise à dresser des chiens à
repérer les cancers du sein juste avec
leur odorat et après il va le lancer une
grande étude clinique pour pouvoir faire
de cette méthode
une vraie méthode reconnue
scientifiquement dans un registre un peu
plus glauque et un peu plus mystique
aussi vous avez peut-être déjà entendu
parler d'eux car le chat qui sont la
mort alors le chat qui sont la mort ça
veut pas dire qu'ils sont très mauvais
ça veut dire qu'il est capable de
détecter les gens qui sont en fin de vie
rien qu'en les renifle ans en tout cas
c'est ce que prétend le personnel de
l'unité de soins pour personnes âgées de
rhodes island où vit aux quarts et c'est
ce que prétend aussi le docteur david
dosa qui lui a écrit un livre sur lui
carrément alors comment il s'y prend
oscar est bas il se balade dans le
service il va renifler les patients et
le personnel affirme que si s'installe à
côté de l'un d'eux pour lui faire un
petit câlin le patient meurt dans les 2
à 5 heures et le char est avec lui
jusqu'au bout alors on est d'accord y'a
rien de scientifique là dedans il ya des
médecins qui disent que oscar il
pourrait flairé l'odeur de la mort comme
les chiens flers l'odeur des tumeurs
mais aucune étude n'a été menée
donc tant que c'est pas prouvée
et puis dans un registre complètement
différent il ya les phéromones
je pense que ça va vous parler mais on
va quand même refaire un petit point une
hormone c'est une substance chimique
produite par le corps qui a pour but de
déclencher une réaction
c'est un messager qui dit aux fauteurs
quelque chose mais c'est un messager
interne une phéromone c'est aussi une
substance chimique produite par le corps
qui a aussi pour but de déclencher une
réaction
mais chez quelqu'un d'autre c'est aussi
un message et qu'ils transportent aussi
un message comme par exemple prévenir
d'un danger en espérant obtenir de
l'aide ou donner un maximum
d'informations à tous les individus
autour qui pourrait éventuellement
envisager une activité de type
reproductrices en espérant obtenir du
sexe chez les êtres humains ces
particules elles sont sécrétées dans la
sueur et les sécrétions génitales
donc elles font partie de notre odeur
corporelle a une ou deux subtilité
prennent d'abord l'organe voméronasal ou
organes de jacobson qui est chargé de
détecter les phéromones et qui est
située juste ici c'est vrai qu'il est
situé pas loin de tout ce qui nous sert
à sentir les odeurs mais pas tout à fait
c'est ce qu'on appelle le système
olfactif accessoires donc est ce qu on
est vraiment dans des odeurs à
strictement parler
l'autre raison c'est que chez l'humain
ce fameux système il s'est pas mal
atrophiée au fur et à mesure de
l'évolution est qu'aujourd'hui les
scientifiques sont pas d'accord sur sa
fonction exacte on dit qu'elles sont
censés déclencher l'attirance sexuelle
notamment en fonction de la
compatibilité entre deux individus
mais est ce que on est vraiment encore
équipés pour décoder toutes les
informations qu'elles contiennent pas
seulement bon mais en tout cas elles
sont là ça c'est sûr donc vous avez bien
compris notre odeur corporelle c'est un
cocktail un cocktail 2000 fragrance
mille substances chimiques plus ou moins
détectables plus ou moins identifiables
mais en tout cas un cocktail unique
c'est une vraie carte d'identité
d'ailleurs les gens qui recherchent les
criminels et plus parle il parle
aujourd'hui d'emprunter le fatigue de la
même façon qu'on parle d'empreintes
l'institut de recherche criminelle de la
gendarmerie nationale est en train de
développer une technologie qui permet
d'identifier un suspect grâce à son
odeur corporelle
parce qu'on laisse pas forcément de
l'adn mais on laisse forcément son odeur
corporelle partout où il passe
voilà à détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien et nickel au niveau romain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]